and every time a shark like rips
someone's arm off
like everybody defends the shark like
when that shark ate the guy in Egypt and
they were clubbing him the Arabs thank
God for Arabs sometimes not always but a
lot
sometimes you know because it's not
great with this ass in the face of the
women all the time and throwing the gays
off the roof I certainly don't like that
um and that's why Beverly Hills Hotel
people said why do you go there uh
because they're from the country where
they throw the gays off the roof and I'm
like if I have to have lunch the Waldorf
I'll throw myself off the roof because
it's not good the John George or Beverly
Hills is not good